qualifiée galina jay kay et va de
volontaires est un euphémisme
c'est à dire se connaît nombre de
soldats par leur prénom et collecte tout
le nécessaire pour qu'il ne manque de
rien elle se dit fier de voir sa ville
aussi unis c'est tout l'inversé dans sa
famille sa mère et son frère gradé dans
la police lift en crimée annexé par la
russie en 2014 moi moi je fais pas chez
nikko rigueur
c'est normalisation complète viennent
moins chez nous quand jacob rente et de
pittsburgh
il ya un beau jour harmoniser nos
voitures et autres monstres entre les
roseaux mauvaise il estimé
lise né de père anglais fondre au match
et le père n'a divine
songeur fumée dit m
la guerre n'est pas encore en ville mais
à odessa elle a déjà semé son lot de
blessures intimes sur cette plage en
creuse pour fabriquer des sacs de sable
qui serviront à renforcer barricadé
checkpoint
[Musique]
derrière les sourires la solidarité des
regard nostalgique du may cry ne sait
pas quand il reverra ses parents restés
dans les territoires séparatistes du
double
à odessa une minorité fait profil bas
celle qui n'a pas l'intention de
résister à l'avancée des troupes russes
[Musique]
et
alexandre évitent le sujet avec ses amis
mais bientôt dit il nous ne nous
parleront plus